le quoi qu'il en coûte nous en sommes
déjà sortis je veux que les choses
soient très claires entre nous nous
avons protégé notre économie et nous
avons fait ce choix collectivement et
j'entends pas beaucoup de voix
d'ailleurs pour critiquer les choix
stratégiques du gouvernement en matière
économique pendant cette crise seront
protégés des salariés évitez la vague de
faillites éviter la vague de chômage qui
se seraient soldés non seulement par une
crise économique mais par une crise
politique
digne de celle des années 30 donc nous
n'avons pas compté l'argent public parce
que c'est est responsable de le faire
mais maintenant que l'économie française
on redémarre que nous avons des
perspectives de croissance à 6 % je le
dis le quoi qu'il en coûte c'est fini
nous sommes passés au sur mesure nous
continuerons à soutenir ceux qui en ont
besoin je leur donne rendez-vous lundi
prochain 30 août le monde de la culture
les restaurateurs les bars les hôtels le
monde du tourisme les voyagistes tout ce
dont a parlé également geoffroy roux de
bézieux nous regarderons ce qu'ils ont
perdu du chiffre d'affaires pendant
cette crise sanitaire pendant ces mois
de pas sanitaires et 12 aides auront ce
qu'ils ont perdu de l'argent à cause des
réglementations sanitaires mais pour le
reste que l'économie soit libre qu'elle
crée des emplois et qu'elle crée de la
richesse sans le soutien de l'état
[Applaudissements]